So now let's take a look at the
specific
Method that's based on regression.
Now this is one of the many different
methods.
In fact, it's one of the simplest
methods and I choose this to explain
the idea because it's simple.
So in this approach, we simply assume
that the relevance of document with
respect to query is related to a linear
combination of all the features.
Here are used Xi
to
denote the feature, so Xi of Q and D is a
feature.
And we can have as many features as we
would like.
And we assume that
these features can be combined in a
linear manner.
And each feature is controlled by a
parameter here.
And beta is a parameter that's a
weighting parameter, a larger value would mean
the feature would have a higher weight
and would contribute more to the
scoring function.
The specific form of the function
actually also involves a transformation
of the probability of relevance.
So this is the probability of
relevance.
We know that the probability of
relevance is within the range from 0
to 1.
And we could have just assumed the
scoring function is related to this
linear combination, right?
So we can do a linear regression, but
then the value of this linear
combination could easily go beyond
one, so this transformation here
would map the zero to 1 range
to the whole range of real values.
You can verify it by yourself.
So.
This allows us then to connect the
probability of relevance which is
between zero and one to a linear
combination of arbitrary features.
And if we rewrite this into a
probability function we would get the
next one, so on this on this equation
then we will have the probability of
relevance.
And on the right hand side we would have
this form.
Now this form is clearly non negative and
it still involves the linear
combination of features.
And it's also clear that
if this value is, this is actually
negative of the linear combination in
the equation above, if this,
This value here.
If.
This value is large, then it would mean
this value is small and therefore this
probability this whole probability would
be large and that's what we expect.
Basically it would mean if this
combination gives us a high value, then
the documents more likely relevant.
So this is our hypothesis.
Again, this is not necessarily the best
hypothesis, but this is a simple way to
connect these features with the
probability of relevance.
So now we have this combination
function.
The next task is to see how we to
estimate the parameters so that the
function can actually be applied without
knowing the beta values, it's harder to
apply this function, so let's see how
we can estimate beta values.
Let's take a look at a simple example.
In this example we have 3 features.
One is BM25 score of the document and
query one is the page rank score of the
document, which might or might not
depend on the query.
We might have a topic sensitive
Pagerank that would depend on query.
Otherwise the general page rank doesn't
really depend on query and then we have
BM25 score on the anchor text of
the document.
These are then the feature values for a
particular Doc document query pair.
An in this case, the document is D1,
and the judgment that says that is
relevant.
Here's another training instance and
with these feature values.
But in this case it's not relevant.
OK, this is overly simplified case
where we just have two instances.
But it is sufficient to illustrate the
point.
So what we can do is we use the maximum
likelihood estimator to actually
estimate the parameters.
Basically, we are going to predict the
relevance status of the document that
based on the feature values that is
given that we observe these feature
values here.
Can we predict the relevance?
Yeah, and of course the prediction will
be using this function.
That you see here.
And we hypothesize that the probability
of relevance is related to features in
this way, so we're going to see for
what values of beta.
We can predict the relevance well.
What do we?
What do we mean by predicting the
relevance well?
we just mean in the first case
for D1.
This expression here right here should
give a high values.
In fact, we hope this to give a value
close to one, why?
because this is a relevant document.
On the other hand, in the second case
for D2, we hope this value will be
small.
Why? Because
It's a non relevant document.
So now let's see how this can be
mathematically expressed.
This is similar to expressing the
probability of document.
Only that we're not talking about the
probability of words, but talking about
probability of relevance one or zero.
So what's the probability of this
document?
The relevant if it has these feature
values.
This is just this expression, right?
We just need to plug in the Xi(s).
So that's what we will get.
It's exactly like.
What we have seen above, only that we
replaced these Xi(s) with now specific
values, right?
So for example, this .7  goes
to here and this .11.
goes to here.
And these are different feature values
and we combine them in this particular
way.
The beta values are still unknown, but
this gives us the probability that this
document is relevant if we assume such
a model.
OK, we would want to maximize this
probability, since this is a relevant
document.
What we do for the second document?
Well, we want to compute the
probability that the prediction is non
relevant.
So.
This would mean we have to compute 1
minus.
This expression.
Since this expression.
Is actually the probability of
relevance.
So to compute the non relevance from
relevance we just.
Do 1 minus the probability of
relevance.
OK.
So this whole expression then just is
our probability of predicting these
two.
Relevance values one is 1 here, one is zero
and this whole equation is our
probability.
Of observing a 1 here.
And observing a zero here.
Of course, this probability depends on
the beta values.
Right so then our goal is to adjust the
beta values to make this whole thing
reach its maximum.
Make it as large as possible.
So that means we're going to compute
this.
The beta is just the parameter values
that would maximize this whole likelihood
expression.
And what that means is if look at the
function is we are going to choose betas to
make this as large as possible and make
this.
Also, as large as possible, which is
equivalent to, say, make this the
part as small as possible.
And this is precisely what we want.
So once we do the training now we will
know the beta values.
So then this function would be well
defined once beta values are known.
Both this and this.
Would be completely specified, so for
any new query and new documents, we can
simply compute the features.
For that pair and then we just use this
formula to generate the ranking score
and this scoring function can be used
to rank documents for a particular
query.
So that's the basic idea of learning to
rank.